como hemos visto en vídeos anteriores la
derivada con respecto de x de
el logaritmo natural de x es igual a 1
entre x y lo que quiero que hagamos en
este vídeo es utilizar esto que sabemos
para encontrar la derivada con respecto
de x de el logaritmo de x pero de
cualquier base y para poder hablar de
eso vamos a llamarle logaritmo base a de
x donde a es una base arbitraria puede
ser cualquier base y como vamos a
encontrar esta derivada bueno pues la
clave aquí es algo con lo que
seguramente ya estás familiarizado de
tus clases de álgebra o pre cálculo la
clave aquí es hacer un cambio de base
porque por ejemplo vamos a hacerlo por
acá si tenemos el logaritmo base a debe
y lo quiero cambiar a otra base digamos
que lo quiero cambiar a la base c esto
es igual a logaritmo base c
dv / logaritmo base de a tomamos el
logaritmo base se debe entre el
logaritmo base de a y esto que tenemos
aquí es muy útil si no lo habías visto
antes lo demostramos en otro vídeo aquí
mismo en khan academy ahora esto es muy
muy útil porque por ejemplo tu
calculadora tiene un botón que dice 'lo
pero ese botón lo que hace es sacar el
logaritmo base de 10 por ejemplo si
tienes 100 en tu calculadora y aprieta
el botón log lo que te da es un 2 porque
estás sacando el logaritmo base de 10 de
100 siempre que veas lo de 100
implícitamente es logaritmo base de 10
pero en la calculadora seguro también te
vas a encontrar con el logaritmo natural
el logaritmo natural de x es igual a
logaritmo base
de x ahora nosotros no siempre queremos
sacar estos dos tipos de logaritmos nos
gustaría poder sacar cualquier tipo de
logaritmo y esta es la forma como lo
hacemos por ejemplo si quisiéramos sacar
el logaritmo base 3 de 8 lo que tenemos
que hacer es sacar el logaritmo base de
10 de 8 y dividirlo entre el logaritmo
base 10 de 3 y aquí estos logaritmos
implícitamente son base 10 claro que
tenemos el mismo resultado si sacamos el
logaritmo natural de 8 y lo dividimos
entre el logaritmo natural de 3 y este
botón de logaritmo natural seguramente
también lo tienes en tu calculadora y lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
aprovechar al máximo el logaritmo
natural porque ya sabemos cuál es su
derivada entonces esta derivada se puede
escribir como la derivada con respecto
de x
de logaritmo natural de x logaritmo
natural de x / logaritmo natural de a
logaritmo natural de a pero espera el
logaritmo natural de a es una constante
entonces esto lo podemos reescribir de
esta forma como 1 / logaritmo natural de
a por logaritmo natural de x y cuál es
la derivada de esto bueno pues esta
constante podemos simplemente sacarla y
nos queda 1 / logaritmo natural de a
la derivada con respecto de x de
logaritmo natural de x que nosotros ya
sabemos que es igual a 1 entre x así es
que este término de aquí ya sabemos que
es 1 / x y entonces lo que nos queda es
uno entre el logaritmo natural de a por
uno entre x o sea 1 entre logaritmo
natural de a
x y es bastante útil saber esto ahora
podemos sacar todo tipo de derivadas por
ejemplo si ahora yo te dijera que f de x
es igual a logaritmo base 7 de x ahora
ya sabemos que f prima de x es igual a 1
entre el logaritmo natural de 7 por
equis y por otro lado si dijéramos por
ejemplo kg de x es igual a menos tres
por el logaritmo base que va se lo vamos
a poner pongámosle base pi oye pi es un
número
digamos que gx es menos 3 por logaritmo
base pi de x entonces cuál es la
derivada de g de x pues esto sería igual
a 1 entre a no espera me equivoqué
tenemos menos 3
este es el -3 de por acá y luego tenemos
que dividir entre el logaritmo natural
de pi o sea el logaritmo natural de la
base logaritmo natural de pi por equis y
listo ya terminamos ojalá ya tengas una
muy buena idea de cómo se hacen todas
estas cosas